the Joe Rogan experience a thing about
boxing that has my imagination and my
fascination continually sparked is the
the finite nature of the tools and the
weapons that you have to use yeah right
mm-hmm I respect and appreciate MMA but
it's almost like the antithesis of that
and that they have so many things they
can use and whatnot it's it's an
entirely different discipline yeah but
you're coming from a martial arts
background so I grew up on comfortable
movies right and so when I started
watching this [ __ ] these guys were in
G's they were like you know I say it's
the Gracie's breaking arms one night and
that made sense to me and I understood
why a boxer wouldn't fight a karate man
or a judo guy whatever because that's
what the science is for me like what you
can do with these two hands and I'm
there two feet of the only way you can
evade and all of that but why can't the
karate man why is it there like a Bruce
Lee of MMA as a martial art right as a
martial artist can you still believe in
like one discipline after all this MMA
is proven it doesn't work there's no
real one discipline that will work best
in MMA you have to know everything but
if I was gonna say what disciplines the
most important I would say wrestling
because if you can't keep a guy from
taking you down
he's gonna be on top of you he's gonna
hold you down he's gonna punch you in
the face it's a giant advantage to be
able to hold a guy down be able to punch
his face in and you can't really do much
when guys on top of you that said from
there you have to understand jujitsu
because if you don't you could hold a
guy down then all sudden he wraps his
legs around your neck and you caught a
triangle and you go to sleep and every
fight starts standing so you have to
have some understanding of striking
because you have to be able to close the
distance but there's no one way to do it
that's what's interesting to me it's
like there's Anderson Silva's way to do
it it was the greatest middleweight of
all time and his way to do it was
through striking he would just stay up
with guys and just [ __ ] them up with
timing and precision and Muay Thai but
then there's guys like Daniel Cormier
would take guys down and beat the [ __ ]
out of them choke them you know and
there's a bunch of different people that
with a bunch of different style
in between but if you look at the
majority of world champions the majority
except maybe a couple weight classes
they're dominated by wrestlers
[Applause]